let's get into the sports performance
thing there'll be lots and lots of
people listening that are athletes and
want to try and maximize their
performance what did you learn about
breath's impact on athletic output
i learned that athletes are more
concerned with efficiency than anyone
especially competitive athletes that's
what it's all about who can run most
efficiently so you can beat your
competitor right
we've got 11 pounds of muscles
operating our respiratory system and so
many athletes are focused on every other
muscle i'm going to work on my wrists
today and now i'm going to work out my
neck and my ankles you're not focusing
on the muscles that are delivering
energy to you
when you're competing and i think that
this has been so chronically overlooked
for so long and now people are really
cluing into it so
i will say that i've talked to some of
the real leaders in the field brian
mckenzie's a good friend patrick
mcewen's a good friend these are people
who have been training elite athletes
for decades
on the first thing they do is they have
them breathe correctly uh they said
before anything else that's what they
start with so
what they've found and there have been
numerous studies on this is performance
will improve after you get over that
hump
of becoming a nasal breather your
performance will go down at the
beginning and this is what a lot of
athletes don't want to see they don't
want to see their performance go down
but once you acclimate acclimate slowly
your performance by and large
and this is what they have told me with
hundreds and hundreds of people that
they've worked with will improve and
then your recovery times will improve
your vo2 max will likely improve you can
likely build more blood to more red
blood cells
so you're able to do this because you're
breathing in line with your metabolic
needs most of us when we're competing or
working out are breathing too much that
will trigger an excess of lactic acid
which will make it harder for us to
recover it will also
trigger constriction in our blood
vessels right at the time when we really
need oxygen
if this is correct and it's more
efficient for us to breathe
slower through our nose
why does our body want to do anything
else
because our bodies are acclimated to
have a very low threshold of co2 so what
they're finding now and there's been a
lot of research done on this in the past
but now past and but now
there's a lot more interest in this so
what they're finding is that need to
breathe is not dictated by oxygen okay
it's dictated by co2 right now if you
exhale and hold your breath
you're gonna feel this nagging need to
breathe after a while okay that's
dictated by rising levels of co2 and the
more acclimated you get to being
comfortable with more co2 in your body
the more oxygen you can deliver to your
hungry cells
so whenever you feel that
i really need to breathe i really need
to breathe
over breathing is not going to deliver
more oxygen to you okay you want to
breathe in line with your metabolic
needs and that almost always is way
slower than you think it is pulse
oximeters can help do this breath
holding exercises can really help get
over that that hump which is exactly why
they're using so many of these for elite
athletes but don't take my my word for
it talk to the athletes who have
converted to nasal breathing who have
adopted healthy breathing practices and
uh it's been a complete game changer for
these people did you watch elliot
kipchoge's breaking two attempt you see
him sprinting towards the finish line
and the guys i i don't i can't work out
if his mouth is shut or not but it's not
far off it's definitely not wide open
and he just looks it's the same cadence
it's the same facial expression
the man's just zen i wouldn't be
surprised if he's a very very heavy nose
breather
uh of course he is
so i want to mention one thing
especially for the people who really
like edging into that zone four zone
five level there is a time and a place
for everything and this is what i've
learned from brian mckenzie who works
with elite olympians so if you're about
to dunk on someone's head like it's okay
to open your mouth
take a huge breath if you look at
michael jordan right before he's dunking
he takes this huge breath and dunks
that's perfectly fine as long as you use
that mouth breathing as a tool
just like those people in that submarine
right they're using their mouth
breathing as a tool a lot of people
aren't
used to or even want to get to those
elite states of athletic performance
which is why i don't mention this too
often but for those people who do yeah
resetting with some mouth breaths if
you've really reached your top
go back to nasal breathing totally fine
and if you look at sania richards ross
who was the the top sprinter for 10
years
check out her um
crossing the finish line and everyone
else behind her mouth breathing
mouth closed
breathing through her nose and kipchoge
is is the same thing it's okay to have
your mouth open a little maybe he's
exhaling a little because he's been
running for two freaking hours at 20
miles per hour
that's fine
but the majority of his breasts i i
guarantee are nasal dominance and
something that joggers can do if you
have a heart rate monitor if you have a
strap the straps are the most accurate
by far
check out your heart rate
when you're nasal breathing versus mouth
breathing and you will see your heart
rate
lower and if you're able to perform at
the same level of endurance with a lower
heart rate
guess what you're doing you're operating
more efficiently and that means you then
have more energy to go a little faster
to go a little longer that's what
athletic performance is is based on
efficiency and breathing has to be a
huge part of this brian mackenzie was on
the show a couple of years ago and he
said he could tell
an athlete's performance simply by
getting them to do a co2 tolerance test
he had a very good indication of what
this athlete was going to be like across
a number of different domains by just
getting them to
do one slow breath from the top okay
you've got as much time as you want
breathe in
fully
breathe out start the clock as soon as
you stop breathing out i'm going to stop
the clock that was it that's the only
test that he needs and on his uh state
app that's the regular
retest that you do right as you continue
to work up through it so yeah it's it's
so crazy he's here's something else so
let's say there might be a lot of people
listening that maybe power lifters
crossfitters they do sort of interval
style work perhaps other athletes
how would you advise someone to recover
in between
sets because am i right in thinking that
we've got the
cadence i.e the speed of the breath and
then the depth of the breath are those
the two main
uh characteristics the two main sort of
parameters that we're playing with when
it comes to breathing
in between reps i think nasal breathing
is so important but i also want to be
very clear here
once you have acclimated truly converted
to nasal breathing is where you're
really going to see these benefits at
the beginning some people may need
surgery okay some people do need surgery
because their nose are so messed up but
a lot of people just need conditioning
just like you need conditioning with
anything else
so there's two different things i i can
talk about before you're conditioned
nasal breathe as much as you can right
it's gonna be uncomfortable but don't
push it like try it for maybe half of
your breath or a quarter of your breaths
at the beginning then go back to your
mouth breathing that's fine at the
beginning that's what you've been doing
but then just gently start increasing it
as you go along
it really helps to be nasal breathing at
night
this will help condition all those
tissues and different structures in your
nose and will help more easily acclimate
your body to what you're doing in the
daytime also nasal breathing wearing a
little piece of tape while you're
answering emails or doing stupid stuff
around the house can really help
condition you to nasal breathe so to
answer your question in between reps is
absolutely when you want the heart rate
to come down a little bit you want your
oxygen to go up and you want to recover
you don't want to be stressing your body
out i can't tell you how many times i
used to see this at the gym is
people working out doing a few reps and
then just it was like this macho thing
to walk around and go
like they're really working out the same
thing on a treadmill on an elliptical
there's people just
you're not doing yourself any favors if
you want to burn more fat you need more
oxygen which means you need to be nasal
breathing more and breathing in line
with your metabolic needs so
it's just basic biochemistry but again
so few of us have heard about this until
recently that's an interesting one so
even though nasal breathing will reduce
your heart rate
which most people would associate lower
heart rate less calorie burning
nasal breathing with lower heart rate
will actually increase calorie burning
your metabolic rate is going to be going
up from lifting weights and your
metabolic rate continues to go up after
you work out right that's where you get
the benefits from the fat burning it's
it's just not always during your
during the workout it's afterwards that
that's the real benefit of exercising
so if you're talking about burning fat
you need oxygen to burn fat and you can
run anaerobically you can do that for a
while it's extremely inefficient that's
an inefficient way to burn you're
burning sugar that's cool but you're
also building lactic acid and and
causing which is fine in small amounts
but but it can cause problems late later
on
so
you want that combination where you want
to be working out into your zone three
zone four you want the heart rate going
up but you also this is what heart rate
variability is you also want it to be
able to go down your your
and the benefits of that fat burning
will be happening after as well if you
go on a three hour jog it will be
happening during that as long as your
fat adapted and you're not just burning
sugar as long as your body can easily
switch over to burning fat and you need
oxygen to do that you also need proper
food to do that
one of the things i've just thought
there
it feels uncomfortable right the co2
tolerance is your i tried to do it today
so i'm listening to the book earlier on
today and i'm going for a jog and i'm
not right james nest is listening well
he's not listening but he's talking to
me so it's kind of the same thing
shut your mouth like breathe breathe
through your [ __ ] nose come on and
i'm jogging along and you feel the
discomfort and it rises and it rises and
it rises and the uh air thirst to want
to breathe more deeply through your
mouth gets more and more compulsive
i've got to guess based on how few
people i've ever seen faint
whilst running
that that is almost all psychological
and very
far your physiological limit for how
much carbon dioxide you can tolerate and
how much oxygen you need and how much
more you need to breathe through your
mouth
is miles away from where your brain
thinks it is
a yes and no that depends on the person
people who are very tolerant for high
levels of of co2 can push it too far
right but then you have
free divers who are almost inhuman in
their abilities
they've measured
brain oxygen levels of 50
in a in a free diver so this is so far
below
what is supposed to support
consciousness but and yet it does so i
can't give you a cut off point what
brian mckenzie does what patrick mckeon
does is they take you through interval
training with with breathing right and
that's what freedivers do as well when
you're in a controlled environment
you're laying down on your couch and
you're just holding your breath for a
minute at a time then you're holding
your breath for a minute and a half at a
time then you're breathing for 30
seconds and holding your breath that's
the best way to acclimate yourself to
co2 while jogging i do not recommend
especially turbo people who really like
to push it to just hold your breath as
long as you can and say i'm not this is
just psychological i don't want to be
responsible for you actually
passing out the floor yeah exactly what
you what you can do are these this
simple interval training where
three seconds in six seconds out right
four seconds in eight seconds out and
maybe you do that you start very lightly
at the beginning this is what i found
really help with with my surfing and
jogging even though i hate hate jogging
i try to do it anyway even walking you
can do this
three seconds in 10 seconds out it's
gonna feel uncomfortable then after a
few days or a few weeks you're gonna be
like hey i'm comfortable with this i'm
gonna push it a little more this is the
responsible way of doing it and you're
gonna notice something that that i
thought was fascinating is you're going
to feel all this heat all this warmth in
like your fingertips in the back of your
neck and this is circulation this is a
vasodilator that's what co2 is it's all
of the circulation if your body has that
circulation say able to process
metabolites it's able to deliver oxygen
it's able to remove other toxins you
want that movement and that circulation
and that's what this breathing allows
you to do so again i would not suggest
doing these epic breath holds while
you're working out but work on the
inhale and exhale ratios
and play around with that and do it on a
very softly and in a mellow way at the
beginning thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe makes me very happy
indeed
peace